I just moved here to New York and I love
it and you're from here hell kitchen
right just down the street can you it
did you did you enjoy the city at all
growing up do you like do you like no I
didn't because it was very rough back
then back then actually it was called
Hell's Kitchen for a reason it's because
at that time a lot of different people
lived in the neighborhood and they would
cook because they're so hot they would
cook on the balconies so it smelled like
Hell's Kitchen CU cabbage with beans the
name that's how the name came yeah oh
you learned something
day now you know you're just bestowing
knowledge left and right I like it well
in the in the documentary like you talk
about pain and regret and that's like
what the character was going through but
a lot of people relate to that so how do
you deal with pain or regret in your
life well you just have to say it's
going to be there it's never going to go
away inev and and I think you just
understand you have to accept it it's
it's part of your history part of your
culture and okay I know it's going to
arrive but I'm prepared for it and it
will pass mhm it's like like a bad storm
yeah it's just but I think people become
disillusioned when they oh well I sought
medical help I've seen psychi and they
think their history is going to vanish
and it doesn't no but in some ways it
can be a motivating force hell yeah you
know even though it started like as a
negative it can eventually end up as a
positive if if you use it instead of
internalizing it use it for fuel I think
so yeah but like what you do you
entertain people and when you're being
entertained is when you kind of forget
your problems for two hours three hours
you know what I mean why do you think I
have nine
jobs I'm like busy busy be yeah I do
like being busy though and I think that
is a thing from childhood like I'm like
okay I must be productive and it not
that it necessarily keeps it at Bay but
I think it gives you a break to maybe
get some perspective and listen to other
people abely there's no question I think
yeah the more you keep yourself
motivated mhm the better off it is yeah
um I heard that you said Rocky couldn't
have existed without Carl weather right
no I you know it first of all Rocky's a
I know look at that boat it's so iconic
wow yeah yeah yeah he was
amazed I couldn't find anyone to play
the part no one had all the tools either
their voice was too high or they weren't
big enough or they weren't athletic
enough it's really hard to find yeah
everything in a person so it was about 8
o'clock at night and the guy I wanted
that he quit because he wants to go in a
bicycle race competition went really so
obviously he was not a serious actor
yeah he was a physical type so I'm
sitting there and at 8:30 this fella
comes in and he's
mad what am I here for I mean cuz no one
gets like you don't have an audition at
8:30 at night you're like at the bottom
of the barrel you know what I mean you
know what I mean it's like lunch it's
like 8:30 so he comes in they pulled him
off a plane going to Oakland so he's
coming and he's fired up all right what
do I do I go voice good voice is good go
check that he go and he takes his jacket
off shoulders forever check check and
then he look I went good looking yeah
nice I didn't expect that you know cuz
he's a boxer tough and then we start and
tough then we started to get up I'm
telling you he goes pow
poww damn like it's like a pecker hit me
oh my God checked and then he goes I
would have done better if you at least
hired a real actor instead of uh what do
you what's this guy do work in the
office I no he's Rocky it would all
right how you doing Ro he like
there and I go it's gu arrogant got
it but you need it you know what I mean
I wanted that I wanted him to have this
like Muhammad Ali he had it all he had
charm he had this he had heart he Soul
so I I was stunned when it happened I
was like Crush I didn't think he would
ever die you know he's like Superman
yeah yeah so I look back now with fond
fond fond memories because it's never
going to happen you know when have you
have those seminal moments of Crossroads
it's like certain chemistry on certain
it's impossible to duplicate you know
it's like if they take a group let's say
the Rolling Stones right you take Mick
Jagger out it's over yeah you take mck
Jagger the solo I don't think it works
either there's something about that
combination that was so unique that you
can't you can't mess with it yeah and I
think that happened with Rocky everybody
in it was like sort of Born to play the
part yeah he I love and when it works
out like that that's why it's so
successful yeah it is it is his Netflix
documentary is called fly and a new
season of his Paramount plus series The
Family SK starts February 21st the show
also Stars his family so everybody let's
welcome them right now please say hello
to scarlet cinee and Sophia Stallone and
their mama Jennifer flaven
[Music]
[Applause]
Stallone
oh my gosh welcome to the show it like
no one unattractive is allowed in your
family like the whole damn family is
attractive thank you Mak my life very
hard beautiful yes well your life was
already hard I'm looking at four women
that you had in your house for many
years that couldn't have been easy but
speaking of like home life um y'all just
moved to Florida yes yeah we love it why
the move because our older two daughters
moved to New York and then our younger
daughter goes to college in Florida so
we thought they follow us everywhere we
couldn't you know it was such a long
flight so we just thought we' move a
little closer yeah I didn't really
realize that so I have to go to La for
things and I'm like oh my God it's a 5
and half hour 6 hour flight 20 anymore I
was like what um what do you do you like
when they come visit in New York do you
like no
oh I'm going to be honest I'm going to
be honest she said no she goes yeah no
don't be I don't want to lie I don't
want to lie on show I don't want to lie
my mom love her she's OCD with
cleanliness and my dad tries to fix
things for example we had a lamp with no
light bulb so we unscrewed another lamp
to put it in this one and then that one
had no light bulbs so he tries to help
wait did you not use the other one is
that but he makes things a little more
difficult excuse me it's on you guys
light bulb it's really easy go buy more
light
bulb all right so you live with a lot of
women man so like did you have like a
man lucky guy lucky guy lucky guy but
did you have a just a corner for you I
did I did for about 10 minutes and then
it became
police please you guys he had his man
cave he had a big office where he'd
write he had another man cave where he'd
sit and watch Boxing he took over the
entire garage and made it an art studio
for him so our cars were in the front
yard and he would just like paint in the
trust me he was fine oh my God fine they
are such Liars
it's unbelievable this is the best
television your show is amazing my God
Pinocchio all of you Pinos oh my God I
love it I love cut to us having footage
of like exactly what they're
saying so wait so you have a very
athletic dad so did he like play
sports we did every sport in high school
every single one the broke the record
for shop putut my dad thought before
school and this is true every morning
for about four years he'd wake us up
early we'd have to do push-ups sit-ups
swing a golf club throw a shot put I
don't know why shot put that was but he
said the only two things he wanted us to
do in life was know how to swing a golf
club and know how to throw a shot put
and I'm not sure what the second one was
about we were a Top Shot person in our
I'm not sure why they can you guys can
throw a punch too yeah yeah they get hit
hard now that's a good thing you're
teaching you might need that one day
yeah never know not every guy's the
right guy um so did you ever give him
any like mottos to like live by any
advice especially with dudes oh like yes
I actually I said Think Like a Man act
like a woman and you'll figure it all
out because we're not that complicated
okay I mean no all you seriously we just
my wife makes me watch the housewives of
everywhere yeah and I went wow we have
no chance no yeah I mean women are just
active I don't know that you should
necessarily compare most of the women in
the world no
no yes I can I I don't know that's no no
what it is is you guys have such command
of the language I mean you activate you
talk men just can sit there at a
football game go how you doing how are
you doing and that's it for three hours
no now I'll tell you this man I went to
the Super Bowl one time this Clown's
talking to me the whole time and it was
a dude and I was like I did not come
here to meet
you I was like I watching the game so
some of us just saying yeah you have a
couple friends that never stop talking
you fall asleep and go to bed
and that's me I would leave I'd be time
for bed and sneak
upstairs called the police a couple
times to be like go home noise I go
there's a lot of noise coming from the
St own house the cops will show up and
I'm upstairs in the bedroom watching a
western
you're so wait I I got okay cinee so you
this this a true story um did your
father like throw you into sharks at
some point in your life see it sounds
crazy and unfort it sounds like someone
should have called child services but
fair enough it's true it was a
controlled environment it was very safe
swimming with a shark experience and my
dad I was seriously afraid of them he
thought it'd be funny to throw some Chum
in my one piece and shove me right in
and she's also a horrible swimmer and
I'm a bad swimmer so it was just a
really I I I don't think I talked to you
the rest of the trip I was very upset oh
my God I wanted to see if the sharks
fight no you Den
not I got two other daughters I got two
other daughters thank you the fact that
he was like I'm going to put Chum in
there I know well now I know where I
stand on the leaderboard I
know have you gotten him
back I did something a little naughty um
first season I pretended I was pregnant
can you imagine I I did I mean on camera
so it you know she made a birthday cake
with all these goofy Bab but by the way
Kelly it was my mom's idea so
that my mom like baby Parts like you
know I actually thought he was going to
have a heart attack and I say like
Freddy Krueger by way it was on his
birthday oh my
God I love your women so much and your
family we got to Dish it back you know I
know you threw her into sharks with Chum
I did like I'm like you she gets like
five more
things that's hor you guys kept saying
oh they don't bite I it's a shark maybe
you have one there has emotional
problems by the way we all got in the
water guess who stayed on the boat he
did not put sure he to put his toe in
the water we all swam with them the
whole time you can have the water I'm
staying on the land the shark you know
what I mean I'm up already what were
your like initial thoughts cuz this is
letting people in your Liv so what were
your initial thoughts about this I think
we all were a little nervous and we are
all thinking oh my God are people going
to like us hate us and make fun of us
and then I go oh is that a closeup of
me damn I'm hands true that's true now
it's like we can't get them off the
camera I'm like aren't you tired of
being in front of the camera like share
it a little bit it's addicted it's a
it's a burden and a love I love it and a
curs yeah what what about y'all what
about being what about you scar well I
was really nervous to do it but I know
Sophia and cine really wanted to do it
because of their podcast and then they
love like talking to people and
connecting with them so they were like
might as well just bring the whole
family in and just start a show yeah you
can't stop us from Talking we are always
talking we thought it'd be fun to
include our family because we're
different this is like a very unorthodox
kind of family with why would we do a
reality show like we don't really need
to but we're all pretty funny here and
we love like how much love we show we
think oh why don't we just film it for
like a whole
movie stuff your dad does to you is
worth the tell yeah normal yeah exactly
now see I say this my friends think I'm
nuts but I'm always like prepare
yourself like oh you're walking home in
well buddy system like I am constantly
mothering all my friends you have no
idea no he he's like Waits up for them
yeah I said and he'll call them and say
you know you're supposed to be home by
11:30 and they're like we're coming home
he's like no no you need to be in the
car at 11:00 so you're in your bed at
11:30 there's no like walking boyfriend
I really shook them up every one of them
I can't every I was bad it was bad Crush
their hands it was terrible you like I
can't even imagine bringing a dude home
to that I would sneak them around the
like different doors of the house like
she was the boyfriend's friends she'd
always find a way to help us out like so
we could actually have a relationship
have a real life and saw nine guys
walking upstairs and go excuse me it's
bad enough there's one like the
bachelor no they had nine guys coming up
to the room and and our cat but I said
on I'll say no were there were like
years old list summer vacation I had all
my friends over they're making it sound
like I was alone with nine men in my
room I said we were 15 saw all these
boys walking up to our bedroom and I
said s nine is better than one I no it
ain't no it's nine time the problem so I
hold the door I put Furniture against it
they can't close the door oh there has
to be an open door that television yeah
it was an Open Door Policy of oh my God
oh yeah you kidding me that must be so
hard and you know every dude is just
like I'm sorry your dad is
who wait so this new season speaking of
boys this new season is about um a
boyfriend right it's like a lot of it is
about Yeah Yeah so basically my boy my
new boyfriend and I Louie he comes into
the picture and I remember bringing him
over for the first time to film and he's
never been over to my house or anything
like that so he walks in there's five
cameras on him and he goes oh
and he comes in there's five cameras on
him and he goes what a
family oh my god well you warned him
right I kind of but it you know it's I
didn't want to scare him off it's better
if you don't say anything it's better if
you just let it happen I just didn't
want to scare him off I like him too
much and they like him too especially SL
especially slide right slide you like
him he's a good kid do I have a the one
time you've been quiet I know no
I I do like him I like him nice hair
thank good guy very
nice please whenever he comes over you
steal him away from me I will say I
don't know if any well he does that on
purpose so he's not with you so true
that's so true but I I I don't know I
think like for parents in general it's
hard to see anyone worthy of this kid
that you love that's so it's hard it's
love it can appear controlling sometimes
but it is love I agree all right well
give it up for the Stallone my new
favorite show on
television season two of their car plus
series The Family Salon starts February
21st But be sure to check out the new
documentary fly on
[Music]
[Applause]
Netflix thank you guys have a great
night I'm going
home